- I was like I can't ...
(reggae music)
- [Jason] Guilty pleasure,
what are my guilty pleasures,
- [Jennifer] Um.
all that crap's gone ...
- Oh.
- This is so pathetic.
Frozen yogurt?
- Frozen yo-yo.
Chocolate?
Vanilla?
- Whatever you're holding.
- Whatever's in ...
- Whatever you're pumping.
(reggae music)
- [Host] Hair and makeup.
- Hair and ma- it's not a
secret, you're gorgeous.
- [Host] Cheese.
- Oh, for other people.
- She can throw together a cheese board
like you can't believe.
(reggae music)
- Germs, yeah.
Yeah.
- Germs.
- I don't know what happened.
- When did that happen?
- I don't know, because I
used to be a real dirty bird,
and now I ...
- Oh, maybe it's because, that.
Because.
- Oh, because I cleaned my act up.
- You cleaned your act
up and now it's all about
clean, clean, clean.
- Hmm.
- Don't touch that.
- Yeah.
Hotel floors.
- Did you ever when you
were a kid and you'd go
in to buy shoes, and you
weren't wearing socks,
did you put those little, did
you go into that basket thing-
- Peds?
No.
- How dare you.
- That had socks that you could--
(reggae music)
- I don't know, you're not picky either.
You're ...
I don't think so.
- (Scoffs)
- Well, I mean ...
- What?
- Cheese burgers?
- I love a cheese burger.
- See, you're not precious,
like, you're not ...
Beets.
- You hate beets.
- Well, how would I ...
- Can't eat a beet.
Tastes like dirt.
(reggae music)
- This is the emoji queen.
I think that's yours.
Right, laughing so hard she's crying?
- Oh, that's a good one, yeah.
But I also love this one.
- Monkey with hands on eyes, yeah.
- Like you were--
- But her bit moji, though--
- Oh that's, bit moji's really--
- She's a Jedi Knight with all that stuff,
she set us all up.
(reggae music)
- [Jennifer] That's just not gonna happen.
- It's not gonna happen anymore.
- [Host] Okay.
- 90s, in the 90s--
- You will always show up.
- I'm gonna be there, not
early but, I still ...
I'm not gonna go to the
party, that's probably
what I'm gonna call in and say.
(reggae music)
- She's gonna run the ...
- Let's Hang Out at My
House Company, yeah.
Yes, that's amazing.
I do like to throw a dinner party.
- It's a real cozy situation over there.
(reggae music)
- She practices her faces.
She gets ready for the next take,
and she just runs through the six faces--
- That I'm gonna make during the scene.
- Perhaps, and in what order.
- Yeah.
- She goes, 10-1.
10-1 is code for "pee
pee out the tee tee".
- It's what I do.
- Unless it's a big scene--
- There's a lot of water.
- Then it's a 10-2.
- No, wow!
- [Host] Wow.
- Girls don't do that.
- Never, don't you know that?